Probablemente sepan
de los perros de Pávlov,
esa frase que a menudo resume
la investigación del Dr. Iván Pávlov
de principios del siglo XX
en la que demostró
que podemos alterar
los estímulos que provoca
un acto reflejo en los perros.
Lo demostró haciendo
sonar una campana
en los instantes previos
al momento de
alimentar a sus perros.
Luego de sonar la campana
una y otra vez
seguido de un sabroso alimento,
a los perros se les
hizo agua la boca
con solo oír el sonido
de la campana.
Salivaban incluso cuando
no había alimentos.
Este fenómeno no se
restringe a los perros.
Pensemos en el efecto placebo,
en el que una píldora
sin sustancias activas
provoca una respuesta
similar a una píldora
que tiene una sustancia.
Lo que cambia aquí es nuestra
reacción ante la dolencia,
puede que percibamos menos dolor,
aunque la dolencia
en sí no cambie.
O piensen en el amor que los humanos
sentimos por nuestros padres.
Alguien puede decir que
este amor es instintivo
y en parte puede
que tenga razón.
Pero, ese argumento no explica
por qué los niños
que más tarde
son adoptados sienten
el mismo amor
por sus padres adoptivos.
Sin embargo, el argumento
conductista puede explicar
ambas muestras de amor.
Un padre, biológico o no,
se asocia constantemente a cosas como
alimento,
sonrisas,
juguetes,
afecto,
juegos,
protección
y entretenimiento.
Y una asociación
constante de los padres
con estos aspectos maravillosos
o cruciales de la infancia
tiene un efecto similar,
aunque más complicado,
que el alimento en
los perros de Pávlov.
En otras palabras,
si nuestros padres garantizan
cosas muy buenas
o muy importantes,
entonces ellos mismos se tornan
algo muy bueno e
importante en sí mismos.
Y también hay lecciones
románticas que aprender
de las observaciones de Pávlov.
Todos necesitamos alimentos
para sobrevivir, ¿no?
Y alguien que pueda
proveer manjares
que nos hagan agua la boca
puede convertirse en el
equivalente humano de la campana.
En otras palabras,
si uno puede cocinar uno
o más platos deliciosos
para un potencial amor,
hay buenas posibilidades de ser visto
de manera más
favorable en el futuro,
aún si no preparásemos
ese alimento delicioso.
Y, ¿quién no quiere
que el amor de su vida
se babee con eso?
Pero la vida no es solo
salivación y tañido de campanas.
También hay un lado oscuro
en este tipo de aprendizaje
llamado "aversión al sabor".
La aversión al sabor ocurre
cuando ingerimos alimentos
que con el tiempo nos enferman,
y, en respuesta,
evitamos esos alimentos,
a veces por el resto de la vida.
La aversión al sabor es tan potente
que sus efectos pueden verse
incluso si la enfermedad
se manifiesta horas más tarde
e incluso si el alimento en sí
no nos enferma.
Por ejemplo cuando tenemos
gripe y, por accidente,
ingerimos alimentos
momentos antes de vomitar.
En este caso, sabemos
que el alimento
no provocó el vómito,
pero nuestro cuerpo no lo sabe.
Y la próxima vez que
encontremos ese alimento,
es probable que nos
neguemos a comerlo.
Imaginen las consecuencias potenciales
de una falta de cocción
en una primera cita.
Si el alimento enferma
a tu pretendiente
es posible que asocie
ese sentimiento desagradable
no solo con la comida,
sino con tu comida en particular.
Si el episodio es
bastante traumático,
o si vuelve a ocurrir
en una cita siguiente,
la potencial pareja podría
relacionarte con las consecuencias
al igual que
los perros de Pávlov
relacionaban la campana con el alimento.
En otras palabras,
cuando acudas
a tu próxima cita
¡podrías provocar náuseas!
Dice el viejo refrán,
que la forma más rápida
de llegar al corazón
es por el estómago,
suponiendo que no haya
intoxicaciones en el proceso.